so continuing now with more of our
little retrospective of the x-men films
brings us to x-men origins wolverine of
anything like what i said with x-men
last and i don't think it is as bad as
most people make it out to be however it
is closer to being as bad as everyone
says there's a very basic very
fundamental problem we know Wolverine
not only can't he died because he has to
survive to be in the other movies but
with his healing factor he never even
feels like he's really in danger the
second thing is that part of what makes
Wolverine cool is the fact that you
don't know all the details about his
history and filling in those blanks
doesn't make him more interesting it
actually makes him less interesting but
coming back to the healing factor thing
I had to sort of stop an example well
why wasn't that a problem in the
previous x-men movies cuz he's always
had the healing factor why didn't we
have the same feeling of oh whatever
that has to do with the scale of the
story all of the main x-men movie the
stakes were bigger than Wolverine
himself so maybe he couldn't get killed
but the mission could still fail he
could live and they still lose with
x-men origins wolverine because it's
about just him the fact that he can't
die is a really big detriment in
addition to that you can feel the studio
presence there embedding all these
potential spin-offs Deadpool gambit
there was talk of a spinoff there the
studio is thinking in terms of where can
we make even more movies out of this
gambit no organic reason for him to be
there at all and then of course there is
Deadpool now he's perfectly cast
incredibly well played but completely
poorly utilized in terms of script and
the story he get a lot of day the White
Queen was tossed in there very
haphazardly Cyclops just was kind of
shoehorned in there let's just throw
everything we've got
not into this thing and the hope it
comes out good and well it didn't the
special effects don't hold up
particularly well either the effects in
the previous ex my move it's not that
the effects were necessarily better but
they were used more intelligently that
we used more sparingly and they did more
to hide when they were using special
effects whereas x-men origins wolverine
days go ahead look at this green screen
computer graphic clause why for all my
bitching there is some stuff that works
in here Hugh Jackman still works liev
schreiber as Sabretooth oh oh he's good
he's menacing he's intimidating he's fun
it makes me really wish that he had been
Sabretooth in and that first x-men will
be too but again we've got sort of the
prequel issue which is that he should be
the final confrontation that Wolverine
has but he can't be because he has to
survive to appear in x-men 1 and throw
that all together and you have easily
the worst x-men movie to date on that
note this council geeks is a jerk